ANDREW WALES: Hi, everyone.
My name is Andrew Wales.
I'm a developer programs
engineer on the Google
Analytics team.
Today we're launching actually
a brand new Developer Live
series from Google Analytics
called "Behind the Code." And
actually, on this series we're
not only going to showcase
some new GA features in
technology, but also give you
a chance to hear directly from
some of the engineers, product
managers, and others on the GA
team who are behind the scenes
designing, building, and
ultimately delivering this
technology to you.
So for today's inaugural
episode, we're going to be
talking about Google Mobile
App Analytics.
Recently we launched a brand new
Reports and also version 2
of the Android and iOS SDKs.
Both of these are just recently
out in public beta,
so anyone can go use them.
And to help me talk about Google
Mobile App Analytics,
we have with me Jim Cotugno, who
is a software engineer, a
driving force behind
the Mobile SDKs.
So Jim, it's good to
have you here.
JIM COTUGNO: Well
thanks, Andrew.
ANDREW WALES: Thanks
for joining us
on our first episode.
You're a brave man.
So just to start, I'll
jump right into it.
Can you tell us just a little
bit about what your role is on
the Google Analytics team, and
how long you've been working
with Mobile App Analytics?
JIM COTUGNO: Sure.
So I'm responsible for the
Mobile App A Analytics SDKs,
iOS and Android.
I've been working on them
since December 2010.
And since that time, we've
enhanced the V1 SDKs, what I
call the V1 SDKs.
And also we started looking
at what app users or app
developers really needed
for Analytics.
And the product of that effort
is what you see today with the
App Analytics beta.
ANDREW WALES: Cool.
So for developers who maybe were
using V1 since way back
when you were first working on
it, what's new that they
should know in a nutshell
that's new and exciting?
JIM COTUGNO: Well, I think the
biggest thing that's new is
that we have a whole new set of
reports which are focused
on apps instead of websites.
Those of you who are using the
V1 SDKs know that you're
reporting to basically a web
Analytics reporting framework.
But with the V2 SDK, we have
app-specific reports that app
developers want to see.
The other thing that the V2
SDKs bring to you is that
they're more streamlined, so
they're hopefully less
intrusive on your application.
And also they're
easier to use.
And I guess the final feature is
that you have access to the
whole suite of Google Analytics
features, not just a
small subset of them like
you did before.
ANDREW WALES: Cool.
And I think I've got a ton of
questions for you about all
the stuff that's new.
But before doing that, I kind
of wanted to just step back.
And maybe for some developers
out there who aren't yet using
Analytics in their app, can you
just give us a brief-- if
you're not already using some
kind of Analytics package in
your app, why do you think
it's a good idea?
JIM COTUGNO: I think it's a good
idea because you build an
app and you want people
to use it.
But you really don't have
any idea of how
they're using it or why.
So Analytics brings that to
you so you can see what
features of your application
users like, what features they
don't like.
You can see where your
application's popular.
And in my previous life, one
of the things we wanted to
know is which countries were
people buying our app from.
And then we would actually
put the effort into
internationalize or localize the
application based on the
countries that were popular.
So that's something you can
use Analytics to find out.
You could find out if your app
is funded through advertising.
You can use Analytics to track
how successful your app is in
terms of advertising dollars,
how much money are you making,
that kind of thing.
ANDREW WALES: Pretty key for
a lot of developers.
And for developers who maybe
have used our JavaScript
libraries on the web but haven't
yet tried native
app-tracking on Android or
iOS, how similar is it to
doing an implementation
on Android or iOS?
JIM COTUGNO: So obviously apps
and websites are different.
But where possible, we tried
to keep the two in sync.
So you have the concept of a
tracker on the web Analytics,
and you also have that in
app Analytics, as well.
And you have the types
of beacons or hits
that you can send.
It's very similar
between the two.
You have events.
You have a user timings.
You have social.
You have e-commerce.
And for apps, you have something
called views, or
screen views, which are very
similar to page views.
And so a lot of the concepts
are the same.
Now as far as apps go, a
couple key differences.
The first one is apps may be
running when you don't have an
connection.
So the important thing there
is that we have to kind of
keep track of the activity in
the app, but then hold it
internally and send it later.
And so that presents a whole
new dimension of things you
have to think about as
an app developer.
How often do you want
to send that data?
You have to balance sending it
quickly versus trying to be
nice on battery usage and data
usage for your app users.
ANDREW WALES: I know that's
something in the new SDKs that
you can configure, how often
you want to send.
JIM COTUGNO: Yeah, so it's
totally under your control.
We try to give you reasonable
defaults to start, but you
certainly can tune it
as you see fit.
ANDREW WALES: Cool, cool.
Great.
So is there any reason you
wouldn't want to use Analytics
in your app?
JIM COTUGNO: I can't
think of any.
ANDREW WALES: Good.
That was a test,
and you passed.
JIM COTUGNO: I passed
that one, huh?
ANDREW WALES: Yes.
Fantastic.
OK.
So let's talk about what's
been released today.
So I mentioned earlier that
we've launched this new
reporting experience.
And we have V2 of the SDKs, and
those are in public beta.
And you've talked a little
bit already about
some of the new features.
But I wanted to run through in
detail, for those who haven't
checked out yet, maybe just go
through and talk about some of
the top new features, top new
reports and data that you can
get from using the new SDK.
And I'll switch to some
visuals, too.
JIM COTUGNO: OK.
So as I said before, we wanted
reports that made sense for
app developers and
for applications.
And so that was our first key
thing, to come up with a set
of reports, and the dimensions
and metrics that support those
reports, obviously.
So, for example, the first set
of reports we can provide for
you is activity on your users.
So we have a new users report,
active users report.
The other thing that people
always ask us is which devices
are people using my apps on.
So we have reports that focus
on not only the devices, but
what operating systems.
There are several versions
of Android out there.
of iOS out there.
And of course, every device has
a different screen size it
seems these days, so
screen resolution
is also very important.
ANDREW WALES: And that kind of
stuff could help you figure
out where to prioritize
your development time.
Right?
JIM COTUGNO: Right.
ANDREW WALES: If not everyone is
using the latest version of
iOS, it probably doesn't
make sense to
rely on those features.
JIM COTUGNO: Right.
Exactly right.
ANDREW WALES: So, yeah, what's
engagement flow?
JIM COTUGNO: So this Engagement
Flow report is
really cool.
You can see exactly how your
users flow through your
application, how do they get
there, which screens do they
go through on their way.
And when they leave the
application, you can see where
they leave it.
So if they're leaving it on a
screen that you thought they
would just do as kind of an
interim step, then maybe you
want to find out why they're
leaving and change your app so
that they stick with
it longer.
ANDREW WALES: Improving
that user experience.
JIM COTUGNO: Yes.
Absolutely.
ANDREW WALES: Exception
Tracking.
This is something that's
totally new.
JIM COTUGNO: Yeah.
So when we were looking at what
app developers wanted to
know about their application
usage, crashes and exceptions
was a big one.
Those of you familiar with the
App Store and iTunes Connect,
you get the top three heavy
hitters in terms of where your
application's crashing,
but not much more.
They have no idea what
kind of frequency
those crashes are happening.
So with the crash and exceptions
report, you can see
all the crashes and exceptions
that are happening in your
application.
And more importantly,
you can see how
often they're happening.
So you can see if your top crash
is happening 1% of the
time, 10% of the time.
Are all your users affected, or
just a very small portion?
It's something I think
is very powerful.
ANDREW WALES: And you
break that down by
app version, right?
So you can see if--
JIM COTUGNO: Certainly.
ANDREW WALES: --a new version
you released has suddenly many
more crashes and exceptions.
JIM COTUGNO: That's right.
That's right.
ANDREW WALES: User
defined timings.
I think this was around
on the web, too.
But this is new for apps.
JIM COTUGNO: Yeah, this is
something we added for apps in
this new SDK.
And I'm surprised that this has
have been adopted pretty
aggressively by app
developers.
So obviously there's a need for
app developers to measure
key timings in their
applications.
How long does it take for
a screen to load?
How long does a purchase take
to happen in your app?
Those kinds of things.
And you can do that with the
user timings that we have.
ANDREW WALES: And this was one
I know that's important to a
lot of developers in terms of
being able to see where the
users are coming from, from
different marketing channels.
So we've had some attribution
before, but we do have a new
Google Play Sources report.
JIM COTUGNO: Yeah, this
one has got a lot of
people really excited.
So you can see how effective
your advertising is in driving
users to your application
using this Google
Play Sources report.
It's very easy to set up.
As you can see there, you can
get an idea of what your
campaigns are doing in terms
of generating revenue if
you're using e-commerce
in your application.
You can also see how many users
are being brought to
your app from the various
marketing
campaigns you have there.
And you can even go further
and see what kind of
activities they're using in
your application, what are
they doing with your app based
on the campaign information.
ANDREW WALES: So all the user's
subsequent activity,
how they use the app, and maybe
any transactions they
complete, those get
attributed back to
that original campaign.
JIM COTUGNO: That's correct.
That's correct.
ANDREW WALES: That's
really cool.
And to set this up in the SDK,
it's pretty straightforward.
JIM COTUGNO: Yeah, just a few
lines in your manifest,
really, for Android.
ANDREW WALES: Cool.
So that's sort of the highlight,
I think, of a lot
of the top features.
Is there anything new from the
SDK perspective, like in terms
of if someone was working with
version one and they're
switching to version two?
Is there anything they should
be aware for Android or iOS?
JIM COTUGNO: So it's easier
and better for you.
ANDREW WALES: That's good.
JIM COTUGNO: So there are
three key things.
Obviously we talked
a lot about the
app-specific reporting.
The other thing when I first
started working with the SDKs
is I noticed that they were
difficult to use.
I got lots of questions on
when do I call close, and
things like that.
In reality, you didn't have to
call close at all, ever.
So we rewrote the SDKs to
address that particular issue
of usability.
And the other thing that I
noticed is that the app SDKs,
the original ones, would crash
fairly frequently.
Some of you probably
went through that.
And in the Android world, they
also would degrade the
performance of your application
itself.
So you could see stutters or
stalls, that kind of thing.
So those are kind of the
problems we wanted to address.
ANDREW WALES: And that's
actually a good segue, because
I wanted to, as part of "Behind
the Code", not only
talk about new features, but
also give people insight into
what you think about when you go
back and go to the drawing
board and come up with new ideas
and how you actually
bring that to market.
So after you had done version
one, I think you touched on it
a little bit already, but
what were some of the
main drivers for you?
Why did the team decide to go
back and take another look at
doing app Analytics?
JIM COTUGNO: Well, we wanted to
address the problems of the
original SDKs.
In particular, ease of use was
probably the key thing we
wanted to tackle.
And then, of course, we have a
goal that the SDKs, no matter
what they did, would never crash
the app or impact the
app in a negative way.
So we tried very hard to
insulate applications from SDK
failures that may happen by
doing a graceful degradation.
So the SDK may decide to shut
down collecting data, but it
won't crash the app if it runs
into certain error conditions.
I talked about easy use.
We wanted you to be able to
pick up the SDK and within
five minutes have some basic
Analytics available to you,
basically five minutes
worth of work.
This was our goal, to
get you started.
So you didn't have to figure out
exactly where to put your
lines of code, how do I write
analytics into this.
So we tried to make it
really easy to start.
ANDREW WALES: Do you feel like
five minutes, is that what
developers need?
JIM COTUGNO: I think we're
kind of in the 10-minute
range, but yeah.
It's easy to get going right
out of the gates.
And then as you want to get
more sophisticated in your
Analytics, then of course
it'll take a
little bit more effort.
ANDREW WALES: Sure.
There's a lot there work with.
And just if anybody's watching
and wants to take a look at
the Getting Started guide, you
can see that it is actually
really simple.
Jim says 10.
I would put it closer to five,
but you can go check it out.
It's at developers.googl
e.com/analytics.
So I guess those were some of
it goals you were looking at
when you were redesigning the
SDKs and sort of the reporting
experience.
Were there any technical
challenges that you ran into
that were particularly
difficult?
JIM COTUGNO: Yeah, there are
couple that kind of made the
project interesting.
For Android, in particular, we
wanted to make sure all the
Google Analytics activity was
off the main UI thread.
Reason being is that
we do things like
connect to the network.
We access persistent store
on your device.
We wanted to make sure that
we'd get out of the way so
that the UI experience for the
user wouldn't be impacted at
all by the Analytics SDK.
And that turned out to be pretty
tricky because there's
timing issues.
Because when you're dealing with
multithread environments,
you have to make
sure everything
can synchronize properly.
And one of the key things that
we have to do is we have to
accept tracking beacons before
we're ready to send them.
So that was exciting.
ANDREW WALES: What
about for iOS?
Was it basically the same
doing the SDK for iOS?
Or is it different?
JIM COTUGNO: iOS is a little bit
easier in terms of keeping
stuff off the UI thread, because
persistent store
issues aren't anywhere near
as difficult to handle.
The one thing, though, in
dealing with crash and
exception reporting, iOS was
actually a little bit more
difficult here because, first
off, there are several types
of exceptions or crashes
that you can encounter.
You have NSException, NSError.
And the other thing is we're
limited in the crash and
exception handling, how
much data we can send.
And I guess this is also true
for the Android, but we have
to kind of pick what we think
is the most relevant part of
the crash or the exception or
the error, and report that.
So that was kind of a challenge
to work through and
figure out what the best
thing to do was.
ANDREW WALES: I should say,
though, that I think from, at
least the way it turned out so
far, tracking exceptions on
iOS is actually pretty
straightforward.
JIM COTUGNO: Oh, good.
ANDREW WALES: Thanks to the
work that you put into it.
One other question may be, just
to follow up on that, and
we talked a little about it
earlier, but in terms of
dispatching data--
Because it works a little
bit differently
from the web, right?
So you're queuing up hits
locally and then you're going
to dispatch them.
Is It's fairly straightforward.
Developers can decide
how often they
want that to dispatch.
And that works pretty simply
across Android and iOS.
Is that accurate?
JIM COTUGNO: Yeah.
I guess the best way
is go over it.
So the idea is that the hits
obviously don't necessarily go
out right away, because you
might not have a network
connection or you might not
want to use the network
connection.
So the app developer has
control over that.
Let me get my thoughts
together here.
So the idea is you have to look
at your application, what
it's doing, and then come up
with a dispatch model that
works best for you.
So, for example, if you're
busy connecting to the
internet and sending data back
and forth, then it makes
perfect sense to send
your Analytics
data at the same time.
So you can certainly do what we
call manual dispatch where
you can call out to the
SDK and say, OK,
send what you got.
Let's go.
Or if your application is in
the background, or if your
application doesn't do any
data network connectivity
stuff, you might want to be more
sensitive to the user's
network data bandwidth and their
battery, and send data
every five, 10, 20 minutes, 30
minutes, whatever makes sense
in your case.
ANDREW WALES: So there's
a lot of flexibility.
JIM COTUGNO: There's
flexibility, and there's a bit
of tension here because you have
the need to not send the
data all the time in order to
be a good citizen on the
device, but then on the other
hand, you need to get the data
off the device as well so that
it's fresh enough to be
included into your reporting.
ANDREW WALES: Right.
So finding that balance
depending on your app.
JIM COTUGNO: Right.
Yes.
ANDREW WALES: What
about sessions?
People might be familiar with
how sessions work on the web.
I know we could probably talk
about this for a while, but--
JIM COTUGNO: We could.
ANDREW WALES: Sessions
are configurable
on both SDKs, right?
JIM COTUGNO: Right.
Sessions, for those of you
familiar with Google
Analytics, sessions are defined
by 30 minutes of
inactivity for the web.
For Universal A Analytics, which
is what the V2 SDKs use,
you could actually change
that timeout value.
Every app developer has a little
bit different notion,
but for apps in general, the
time that the app spends in
front of the user pretty much
defines the session.
So if I bring up an app and work
with that app for three,
four minutes and then go on to
do something else, then the
session length for that
particular session should be
three, four minutes.
Some app developers wanted
to not include
phone calls, for example.
They are a big problem, because
some app developers
want phone calls to change
the session, as it were.
So if I get a phone call, then
I want to end the session and
start a new one.
But then other app developers
want to not end the session
when they get a phone call.
So they see a phone call as just
a temporary interruption.
They want to view the session
as continuing
after that call ends.
But yes, the SDKs give you all
kinds of control over when a
session ends and when it starts,
and how long the
application can be in the
background before you even
start a new session.
ANDREW WALES: Cool.
And I should just make another
plug that we do have developer
guides that walk through how
sessions work on Android and
iOS, and also how you can set
them up to work within the
model that is your app.
So go check it out on
developers.googl
e.com/analytics.
JIM COTUGNO: Yeah, Andrew did a
lot of work on those guides.
ANDREW WALES: I did.
Jim did a lot of reviewing
of those guides as well.
Great.
So I think we talked a little
bit about what's new and also
kind of what went into
it, and some of the
challenges you ran into.
There's a lot of power
in these new SDKs.
There's a lot of new data coming
in to some new reports
that are hopefully going to
be really tailored for app
developers.
I wanted to spend maybe a couple
minutes talking about
what's next, or what you think
is going to be next for mobile
app analytics.
What can you tell us about where
the SDKs are going and
where the reporting experience
is going?
JIM COTUGNO: So,
we're not done.
I can tell you that.
We're going to do more.
We're defining more reports
that we want to add to the
standard report mechanism.
As an aside, I just want to
let everyone know who's
familiar with Analytics on the
web, Google Analytics, that
you have the ability to create
your own custom reports.
And that ability is also there
for app Analytics as well.
But we're also going to bring
in more features that web
Analytics users have that
app Analytics users
don't have access to.
Let's see, what else
I have on that?
I mentioned this tension between
being a good citizen
with data usage and battery life
versus getting your data
off, and we're constantly
looking at ways to improve the
situation so you don't have
to worry so much about it.
So we want to get the data off
faster but be nicer about it.
ANDREW WALES: Cool.
And if you could pick maybe one
feature to just magically
be included in the SDKs
overnight without no code
reviews, just popped in and
it worked out, what
feature would that be?
JIM COTUGNO: I would be out
of a job right there.
For me, the most exciting thing
I can think that we
would love to be able to do
is to do what you can
do on the web now.
If you want to change your
tracking or your Analytics
gathering, it's pretty easy to
do it on the web in the sense
that you can just push out a
new version of your website
and it's all there.
But I want to go farther
than that.
In the app space, I want to
be able to change my apps
tracking collection activities
remotely without having to
push a new version of
the app out there.
So that, to me, would
be the Holy Grail
of application Analytics.
ANDREW WALES: So changing the
implementation on the fly
without having to push something
to Google Play.
JIM COTUGNO: Right.
ANDREW WALES: Is that
all hypothetical?
JIM COTUGNO: Oh, boy, I'd love
to do something there.
ANDREW WALES: Fair enough.
Fair enough.
Cool.
Well, thanks, Jim, for
joining us on this
first "Behind the Code".
I think now we can switch
to maybe some questions.
We have a moderator
page that's up.
Let me--
MALE SPEAKER: And while you're
getting that together, Andrew,
one of the questions came in
over YouTube from Nick.
So this is probably for Jim, but
both of you can take it.
The question is why would
somebody use Analytics Mobile
SDK when almost all SDKs,
including PlayHaven, for
example, already include
Analytics as a component?
JIM COTUGNO: You want
to take that one?
ANDREW WALES: So just
to recap, it's
why use the GA SDK?
MALE SPEAKER: Why use the
Analytics Mobile SDK from
Google if other ad SDKs also
already include Analytics
components?
ANDREW WALES: Oh, that's
a good point.
I think if I understand it
right, I think one of the nice
things about the GA SDK,
especially what we have in
terms of campaign attribution.
Our goal is to sit at the middle
of a lot of different
marketing channels
and efforts.
We do try to give specific
valuable reports for Google
paid marketing when we can, but
our goal is to be a little
more agnostic.
So with GA, you get a platform
that can really plug into all
these different marketing
channels, irrespective of what
ad networks you're using.
And to give you that all in one
place, along with all the
rich features like segmentation
and everything
else from GA.
I don't know, Jim, if you
had anything else.
JIM COTUGNO: Yeah, I was going
to say, just to add to that,
the SDKs themselves are designed
so that any sort of
attribution that you have access
to as an app developer,
you can pass through to the GA
reporting framework, just like
that Google Play sources
report you saw before.
It's not limited to that.
So you can certainly pass
attribution through the SDK,
and we'll keep track
of it for you.
ANDREW WALES: I might add one
more thing, too. is that a lot
of people are using GA for web
tracking, and if you're
already familiar with the
interface and how it works,
maybe you're using the
core reporting API.
In that sense, it's very easy
to then loop in the app
tracking component of GA and
just get up and running that
much more quickly, in addition
to everything that Jim
mentioned as well.
MALE SPEAKER: Eduardo
has a question.
He was asking how the SDK and
Universal Analytics new
features relate.
JIM COTUGNO: The SDK is built on
top of Universal Analytics.
So it uses most, if not all, the
features that UA currently
has available, including--
I guess we never did
talk about custom
dimensions of metrics.
ANDREW WALES: That's right.
JIM COTUGNO: SDK also has those
available, and social
user timings.
And the nice thing about UA from
a good citizen point of
view is that less data is being
sent with each hit.
And then the V2 SDKs follow
that same thing.
They send less data with
each hit as a result.
ANDREW WALES: And one add-on to
that, we didn't talk about
custom metrics specifically.
I think we do a whole GDL
on that, or maybe two.
But there is a big,
comprehensive guide available
at
developers.google.com/analytics
if you want to take a look and
learn more about custom
dimensions and metrics.
So maybe we'll switch to
the moderator here.
Let's take a look.
So the first question, from
Jason: Our hybrid e-commerce
app jumps between native app
pages and mobile web pages.
So what best practices do we use
to one, have seamless and
visitor data, and two, not
double count when looking at
our mobile web page
stats via GA.
JIM COTUGNO: Yeah.
So I don't think we have a good
answer for you on that
right now, but that
is something we're
looking very hard at.
So if I get this right, when you
say mobile web pages, so
you'll have your Analytics
tracking code on those website
pages as well, so that'll like
two different visitors in that
sense, if you're you using
the same tracking ID for
both web and app.
One other note is we talked
about the concept
of these app reports.
The app reports only exist for
profiles that have app
tracking enabled, and they only
get data from the mobile
app SDKs, whereas the web
reports will view only data
from the web tracking.
ANDREW WALES: Right.
So web data goes to web profiles
and app data to app.
Yeah, so I think we have
some ideas for that.
I would say, Jason, informally
I have seen this work when
you're showing your web content
in the context of a
web view within, for example,
an Android app.
I think there are ways, and
I'm hoping to talk to Jim
about that and maybe publish
something later, to actually
have the activity on that page
that's being shown in the web
view be tracked as actually
native, so you can keep it in
one session.
But more on that later.
I think that's still something
we're looking into.
OK.
I want to jump down to a
question about migration,
because I know I've heard
this one a couple times.
JIM COTUGNO: Yeah.
ANDREW WALES: The question is,
is there any way to migrate
the data from the whole
web profile--
they were using SDK V1 with
an old web profile--
to these new app profiles that
we just talked about.
JIM COTUGNO: The short answer
is no, unfortunately.
However, that's something
we know a lot of
people want to do.
A lot of people are
using the V1 SDK.
So again this is something that
we're looking at, and
hopefully we'll have
an answer for you
before too much longer.
ANDREW WALES: So today, probably
the best way--
I mean, you have to create
a new profile and then--
JIM COTUGNO: Well, you would
have to, because your old SDK
is actually reporting against
the web profile.
ANDREW WALES: Right.
JIM COTUGNO: And your
new SDK is reporting
against the app profile.
ANDREW WALES: What do
you think about
dual tagging an app?
I've heard some developers do
that, where they have V1 and
V2, reporting at the same time
to different profiles to try
to ease the transition.
JIM COTUGNO: Yeah, that's
certainly a reasonable thing
to do, certainly in
the short term.
So you won't be able to see your
data together, but you'll
be able to compare it kind
of side by side.
ANDREW WALES: Yeah.
Cool.
JIM COTUGNO: Though I wouldn't
recommend that long term
because you're doubling
up the traffic load.
ANDREW WALES: Sure.
It's more overhead.
JIM COTUGNO: Yeah.
ANDREW WALES: Yeah.
Another question: This
is one that's
definitely come up before.
What's the best way to track
in-app purchases?
JIM COTUGNO: So the best way to
track in-app purchases is
to send your beacons when you
get confirmation that the
purchase has been authorized
or confirmed or whatever.
So you might have to pass
the data in terms of the
transaction and all the amounts
and what not, and then
all the line items through.
And you can do that, I think,
with Android pretty easily.
I'm not as familiar with iOS.
But the key point is you want
to wait until you get a
confirmation and then send.
And at that point, you
can send the beacons.
And that might be a good use
case where you can send right
away because you know you have
an internet connection.
ANDREW WALES: That's
a good point.
JIM COTUGNO: And getting
firm data is nice.
ANDREW WALES: With manual
dispatch, right?
JIM COTUGNO: Yeah, with
manual dispatch.
That's correct.
Yeah.
ANDREW WALES: I should say, I
think certainly the e-commerce
framework that we have in the
SDKs is pretty flexible.
It's really, probably, a
question of determining when
the transaction's been confirmed
and then sending at
that point.
JIM COTUGNO: Yeah, that's your
key time to send it.
The other nice thing about the
V2 SDKs, we made a lot easier
to send the transaction.
It's just one call instead of
many calls like we had before.
ANDREW WALES: That's true.
Also documented on
the developer
site, so check it out.
But do also check out the
iOS documentation for
their in-app billing.
And I believe Google Play has
similar documentation.
I think that's one of the things
we'd like to do is
maybe publish some samples to
make this a little bit easier
for people, so keep an eye
out for that, too.
Let's see.
OK.
Let's go to--
Someone says, I read somewhere
that the new reports will
include how many users opened
your app after download, but I
couldn't identify that
in the reports.
Does that exist?
JIM COTUGNO: Yeah, that's
the New Visitors.
So where we see New Visitors,
New Users, what that indicates
is that many people opened up
the app for the very first
time during that reporting
period.
So I think that's what you're
looking for there.
ANDREW WALES: So if you look
at a report, and you said I
have 50 new users over the past
week, it means 50 people
ran the app for the first
time during that week.
JIM COTUGNO: That's correct.
That's correct.
ANDREW WALES: So I think
that should be it.
So look out for the
New Users metric.
And that's different, actually,
from Active Users.
JIM COTUGNO: Right.
Active Users is how many
different people open the app
at least once during the
reporting period.
ANDREW WALES: Great!
Well, I think that's about all
we've got time for today, but
thank you, Jim, again
for joining us.
JIM COTUGNO: Thanks, Andrew.
ANDREW WALES: Really
appreciate it.
I've got some closing
messages here.
Yeah, just a reminder, another
plug to go to developers.googl
e.com/analytics.
We've got a lot of documentation
about the new
Android SDKs, the
new iOS SDKs.
So check it out, read through
it, and hopefully you can get
started tracking in your
app very soon.
Definitely we look forward to
bringing you more Google
Developer Live events from
Google Analytics, including
some more "Behind the
Code" episodes, so
stay tuned for that.
In the meantime, do make sure
to follow us on Google+.
If you have any more questions,
feel free to post
them to the YouTube page or
catch us on Google+, I guess.
Cool.
Well, that's it.
Thanks so much for joining us,
and see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]